[Music]
on this Saturday night hostage exchange
back
on the anticipation and anxiety after
Hamas delays its next hostage
release plus the scenes of pure joy
after weeks of Agony our interview at
one of the pioneers of AI and there are
lots of moral but also security um
dangers and his concern about how the
new technology is being used in the
conflict
the NHL's mask mandate the Canadian
goalie who defied the league to honor
indigenous
Heritage a digital nomad's Paradise you
can really feel that the whole town
became way more International while
remote workers are converging on a tiny
European
Town global national with bar answerer
good evening and thank you for joining
us it has been a day of fast moving
developments including fears The Fragile
truce between Israel and Hamas could
fall apart but we have breaking news
this evening Hamas has released a second
round of hostages for hours hamast
delayed the hand over of the next group
of captives accusing Israel of breaking
its end of the bargain saying Aid wasn't
getting into the northern areas of the
Gaza Strip This video shows a convoy of
Red Cross Vehicles approaching the Rafa
border crossing believed to be carrying
13 Israeli captives including four
foreign Nationals in exchange for 39
Palestinian prisoners according to
reports the hostages include seven
children and Six Women whose ages range
from as young as three up to 67 and four
tii Nationals who were among the
group at one point today Israel warned
it would resume its war and bombardment
of Gaza unless Hamas abides by the
agreement releasing the second round of
hostages by midnight today's delay is
just a reminder of how quickly things
can unravel M Armstrong has our top
story
tonight as soon as he saw him he was off
Ohad Mund looking for a hug from his
father the 9-year-old spent 49 days as a
hostage with his mother and grandmother
but the family says this moment was
bittersweet ohads grandfather is still
held by Hamas and another member of the
family will never come back my cousin
was murdered on that Saturday so um the
puzzle not cannot be finished cannot be
complete this was another reunion at the
same Pediatric Hospital a father with
his arms around his entire family his
wife and two daughters were all
hostages when four-year-old Raz says she
dreamed of going
home her father says that dream is
coming
true Ohad and four other children were
taken to the same facility along with
four adults the plan is for some
catching up and some gentle
pampering some of oh hadad's friends
dropped by the hospital Saturday the
director of Pediatrics says the nine
former hostages are in good condition
and Hospital staff is avoiding pting
them with
questions they're telling us their
stories and we're listening and we're
exciting with them sometimes trying with
them for some of the hostages being
released meant find find out what
happened to other members of the family
72-year-old Adina Moshe had to be told
her husband had been killed October 7th
she also had to get accustomed to
sunlight because of where she was kept
she was in a tunnel she was not used to
the
daylight and during her captivity she
was disconnected at all from all the
outside
world also released Friday were 10 thae
hostages and one Filipino some of their
families only found out they were were
alive watching the news as it happened
live this woman in Thailand says she
danced in the street when she saw her
daughter and son-in-law were
free she says she hasn't been able to
watch anything with bombs falling and
her daughter somewhere in the middle of
it the wait now drags on for the
families of other hostages holding out
hope there was for one family a bit of
good news one of the released hostages
says they saw 79-year-old h Perry alive
even that sliver of information is more
than they had before and is very very
welcome far Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem
tonight thank you Mike as we mentioned
the hostage exchange stalled largely
because of a dispute about Aid getting
into Gaza Hamas officials say 340 trucks
entered the Enclave since Friday 65 of
which reached Northern Gaza they say
that's less than half of what was agreed
to in the qari broker deal is Israel
earlier said 550 a trucks did reach
Northern parts of the Gaza Strip and
insists it hasn't violated the terms
people in Gaza are making the most of
whatever food and fuel is trickling in
and as David Aken reports gazans are
also using the Paw to return to their
homes that are in
Ruins as the war pauses a chance to see
what the war has wrought tahani al- naar
returned to her home in southern Gaza to
find it destroyed she says it was
destroyed in 2008 and again in 2014 and
as she pulls household goods out of the
rubble she says in
Arabic we will rebuild again we will
rebuild out of stubbornness against the
Jews let them destroy and we will keep
rebuilding elsewhere in this city of
200,000 people Palestinians flock to
Food Markets many thankful for some
signs of normaly after more than 40 days
of War fresh tomatoes pepper peers
eggplant lemon even fresh fried
falafal today's prices are less than
yesterday this resident says goods are
more available but fuel remains a scarce
commodity some here weighted five hours
to fill a tank and still came away with
nothing Israeli authorities permitted
four tankers of fuel and another four of
cooking gas to enter Southern Gaza
Israeli authorities said they were meant
for essential humanitarian
infrastructure such as
hospitals con yunice is just 13 km away
from the Rafa border crossing where the
largest Fleet of Aid trucks assembled
since the beginning of the war were
crossing from Egypt into Gaza and in the
heavily contested North the Israeli
defense minister said trucks had been
deployed carrying Food Water Shelter
equipment and medical
supplies many Palestinians said they
hope the truce would become permanent
but the Israeli military has has warned
no one should return to Northern Gaza
which Israel considers an active war
zone David Aken Global
News and an update from Global Affairs
Canada today over how many Canadians
have managed to flee Gaza to date it
says 473 Canadians permanent residents
and their family members have crossed
the Rafa Border Crossing into Egypt and
they are still trying to make contact
with more than 250 others who are
seeking assistance in Gaza us defense
officials are also oo sing the alarm
over a suspected drone attack on an
Israeli managed container ship the
unnamed American defense source told the
Associated Press the alleged attack
unfolded in the Indian Ocean in
international waters the malta flagged
vessel was apparently targeted by a
self-destructing Iranian drone but the
ship only suffered minor damage with no
injuries Iran has not claimed
responsibility but in recent years the
US has blamed Iran for similar attacks
on Israeli vessels in the same
region an overnight barrage has many
worried in keev following what Ukrainian
officials called Russia's largest drone
attack of the war nearly 75 drones are
said to have been fired in the attack a
record number according to Ukraine's Air
Force and the vast majority were
intercepted but heavy damage was still
seen in Ukraine's Capital as Marty blunt
reports there are fears this may be the
start of an intensified winter campaign
by
Moscow explosions light up the night sky
in
keev as Russia launches its most intense
drone attack on Ukraine since the
invasion began shattering homes
cars leaving many picking up the pieces
and fearful of what's
next they totally destroyed my balcony
and my kitchen this woman cries I don't
know what I'll
do this woman says they heard the sound
of an engine overhead a second later a
blast came the door was smashed and hit
the opposite wall it literally flew
above our
heads kees mayor says at least five
people were wounded including an 11-year
old child in the assault that came in
waves for over 6
hours Ukrainian president vadir zalinsky
condemning the attacks during a ceremony
marking the 90th anniversary of bore a
famine that killed millions of
ukrainians evil was not stopped not
atoned for he says and now we are
stopping it as another winter of War
closes in on Ukraine neither side is
backing down and that's being felt here
in Canada with the recent death of
Joshua mayor a 34-year-old Edmonton
paramedic who went to help Ukrainian
troops in September his family saying
he's believed to have died in a drone
strike and they were notified of his
death on November 12th that tragic loss
just a days after the death of Austin
Laughlin bercier a 25-year-old man from
op pasak Creation in Northern
Manitoba his community lowering their
Flags to half Mass to honor his heroic
efforts he died his life for what he
believed in and help which is helping
others it's coming up on two years since
Russia launched its fullscale invasion
of Ukraine in that time Global Affairs
Canada says nine Canadians have died out
of the thousands who have lost their
lives as this war drags on Mary blunt
Global News
Winnipeg DK shovin that's the former
police officer convicted in the murder
of George Floyd has been reportedly
stabbed in prison Minnesota's attorney
general confirmed chovin was attacked at
a prison in Arizona where he's serving a
21-year federal sentence prisoner
officials say employees had to perform
life-saving measures after an inmate was
stabbed on Friday but they wouldn't
confirm the name of the inmate in
Pakistan a deadly fire ripped through a
shopping center in the country's most
populous city 11 people are known to
have died when the blaze broke out at
the mall in Karachi officials say it was
caused by a generator failure on the
third floor the fire spread to several
call centers above where most of the
victims were working the fire was
extinguished and at least 22 others were
injured the rescue mission to free 41
workers trapped in a tunnel in the
Indian Himalayas for 2 weeks has now hit
a major hurdle the heavy drill that was
brought in to break up nearly 60 M of
debris was damaged on Friday crews are
now resorting to power tools to bust
through the remaining 15 M of rubble
meaning the mission will take much
longer to free the
men The Fallout from ottawa's Fall
economic update coming up the treasury
board president weighs in on prudency
versus the government's priorities
plus the NHL rule up setting a Canadian
goalie and what he did about
it Deputy Prime Minister and Finance
Minister Christia Freeland delivered a
glimpse into the state of her
government's finances in the fall
economic statement while there was a
push for housing in the economic update
there was also an attempt to show some
fiscal restraint Eric senson sat down
with a cabinet minister in charge of
overseeing govern government spending
Anita ananth to find out more about the
approach
Eric Farah it can be a thankless job
managing the government's purse strings
in a time of restraint and cutbacks in
the face of a ballooning deficit and
debt ottawa's fall economic update
demonstrated there was little room for
big spending this week on the west block
treasury board president Anita Anand
insisted the government is taking a
targeted approach on affordable housing
while being fiscally responsible it's
certainly is a economic period where we
need to watch our purse strings as well
as to make sure we're delivering on the
priorities that are so important for our
country Anan a former Minister of
Defense says the military is also
getting more money though the economic
update forecasts a reduction in overall
military spending of almost a billion
dollars from the projections made in
2017 the chief of Defense staff Wayne a
told Mercedes Stevenson this month that
the military may not have sufficient
capabilities personnel and training I am
very very concerned about our lack of
our our Readiness State we have um much
to do to get our Readiness back to where
it needs to be I was in the portfolio as
the minister of National Defense and we
do need to grow our Canadian Armed
Forces we are seeing a shortfall in
Recruitment and we need to make sure
that we are at all times ready the
government's projections are unlikely to
Tamp down criticism from Canada's NATO
allies that this country continues to
fall short of its commitment to spend 2%
of GDP on defense spending that and more
on ottawa's economic update on the west
block
Farah thank you Eric and that interview
with treasury board president IND Anand
is tomorrow on the west block right here
on
global ahead we speak to one of the
Godfathers of AI why he's concerned
about how the tools being used in the
Israel Hamas
conflict
it's been an eventful week in the fast
changing world of artificial
intelligence on Tuesday Sam Altman
announced he's returning as open ai's
CEO four days after he was pushed out of
the company that created chat GPT
several board members have been replaced
and Alman says he's now looking forward
to returning to open
AI joining us now from Montreal is yosua
Benjo one of the pioneers of artificial
intelligence and before we start Mr
Benjo I just want to say congratulations
on winning Canada's most prestigious
science prize earlier this month the
hsbg Canada gold medal for Science and
Engineering thank you um I wanted to
start by asking you about the events
this week now I know you might not want
to get specific about uh the events
surrounding open AI but what does this
bring up for you in terms of the
direction of this
space well the thoughts I have about
this um well first I don't have enough
information I think uh most people don't
um to comment specifically on what's
going on but I think it raises a lot of
interesting question that we should have
in public and uh that is about
governance so what kind of uh board what
kind of uh governance should be uh
directing in which direction these uh
very powerful Frontier AI systems are
being
developed um and uh is this governance
process making sure that the public is
protected because companies are
competing with each other and they have
to survive and uh they might be willing
to cut Corners we've seen that already
in the past not just in the eye but it's
it's a it's a you know property of how
markets work it's a it's also you know
something that makes them innovate
faster sometimes but because of that uh
I think it's really important that the
these industries be regulated that the
um Society puts guard rail to make sure
that yes you can compete but make sure
you don't go through red lines that
could be dangerous for the public um and
for that you need a process you know you
talk about the dangers of of AI let me
ask you this how has AI impacted the
Israel Hamas war in general my
reflection about this is Wars like this
are a kind of accelerator for the
advances in the eye especially you know
in their application in the military um
this might not be a good thing I mean
there are reports that Israel is
choosing AI to to using AI rather and in
the Ukraine war as well to choose
targets so is that something that's
concerning to
you it is I I've been speaking about
that danger for almost a decade now uh
the the issue of using AI uh not just to
recognize people in pictures but that
could be embedded in a drone that could
choose who to shoot and that the
decision to kill is something that would
take place without a human intervention
and that's called the lethal autonomous
weapons uh Killer Robots you know in
simple terms um and and there are lots
of moral but also security um dangers uh
threats to the uh stability of uh our
society's and geopolitical stability
that I think uh require uh a lot of
precaution before we move there too
quickly yosua Benjo thank you so much
for your time as always on this
subject my
pleasure ma if you can work from
anywhere why not this European town that
has become a Haven for remote
[Music]
workers Minnesota Wild goal tender Mark
Andre flurry has become the latest
player to defy the National Hockey
League's ban on promoting or celebrating
special causes last night the Quebec
native took to the ice wearing a
specially designed mask for the Wild's
Native American Heritage night he did so
after being told by the NHL that he and
his team could face significant fines
because of the League's updated
guidelines Around theme nights florry
says he wore the mask to honor his
wife's indigenous Heritage it's still
not clear how the league will
respond there is a small town in
Bulgaria and it is increasingly
attracting a new kind of visitor digital
Nomads they're people who travel and
work simultaneously and since the
covid-19 pandemic their numbers have
exploded Christa hessie takes us inside
the town to find out what's bringing
hundreds of remote workers including
Canadians to the quaint Mountainside
area Ariel fu is on a mission I try to
go to all the most popular dish Nomad
destinations around the world that's why
she's here in bonso Bulgaria this
picturesque Town 2 hours south of the
capital Sophia has become an
international hub for digital
Nomads they gather here to enjoy the
hiking affordable rent and fast
Wi-Fi you can really feel that the whole
town became way more International and
you can really see like who are the nor
man so this is like these crazy people
running around with laptops after the
pandemic untethered people from their
offices digital nomadism became
mainstream exact numbers are hard to
come by but one study found that nearly
17 million Americans describe themselves
as digital
Nomads and many Canadians have adopted
this lifestyle too Ariel fu is one of
them a year and a half ago she left her
Finance job in Toronto to travel the
world I'm original from China I moved to
Canada for school and I feel like I just
didn't feel like a strong sense of
community in
Toronto but here in bonow she finds her
people in the summer off seon the ski
Town transforms into a digital Nomad
village with networking events and
activities almost every night hosted by
the Myriad of co-working spaces that
have opened up in the last few
years like most remote workers here
Finch bergling heard about bonso through
the digital Nomad Grapevine I just want
to find what makes me happy um and this
is the best thing about being inom
you're not limited to anything while the
movement promotes a lifestyle that's
borderless and free community is what
many told us they crave most and they're
willing to travel Halfway Around the
World to a remote Bulgarian town to find
it Christa hessie Global
News to learn more about how the town
became a digital Nomad hotspot and
what's driving the movement tune into
the new reality tonight at 7.m on global
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm faren AER on behalf
of our whole crew here thank you for
spending part of your evening with us
this Saturday tonight's your candada is
bav Vista Bay in New Finland and
Labrador we love seeing your candada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at Global
national.com until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night
[Music]